the ceasefire between houthi rebels and
yemen's internationally recognised
government was first agreed in april
it'll now last for another two months
yemenis have greeted the news with
relief and hope
yemenis are mostly optimistic about the
results we hope the truce will be
extended and other issues that haven't
been resolved over the past period will
be addressed as well including the
opening of roads and crossings
the war in yemen started in 2014 when
iran backed houthi rebels took control
of the capital sanaa forcing the
internationally recognised government to
flee
the saudi coalition joined the war the
following year to try to restore the
government to power more than 150 000
people have been killed during eight
years of fighting u.s president joe
biden and the un have welcomed the move
to extend the truce
the longer we can create
a uh
and keep an a kind of truth bubble
the more we hope
that donors
will continue to fund our operations the
conflicts created one of the world's
worst humanitarian crises the un says
more than 4 million people have been
displaced 19 million others are going
hungry analysts say the truce is a
pathway to peace the institution of a
new presidential council in yemen i
think that's been key because this new
council uh an eight-man council has
really been focused on trying to change
the trajectory of yemen and it was
significant that some of the old war
mongers were removed from leadership
positions in order for this council to
come in so there's everything to play
for now
there is still the problem with tyres a
large city in yemen's south west that's
still under siege
but after eight long years of fighting
and misery there is at least hope among
yemenis that this devastating war might
finally be coming to an end
victoria gatenbee al jazeera